hi i'm marquez brownlee and this is the
wired autocomplete interview
is marquez brownlee okay i think so
what do they know that i don't know
why marquez brownlee why is marquez
brownlee
called mkbhd actually when i got here to
the lobby of the building the security
guard was like can i ask you something i
was like yeah he's like you're mkqbh and
i was like yeah close enough i just i
made it to be shorter and easier to
remember than my name mkb
is my initials
hd
is high definition it'll always be hd
i'm not changing it to 8k or anything
crazy hd includes 8k so that's why it's
on qbhd
so why is marquez brownlee so popular
that's a good question i think it's uh a
little bit of skill and a little bit of
luck combining with opportunity i
started making videos a very long time
ago and it sort of had the opportunity
to build up since then so it didn't just
become popular it didn't explode onto
the scene but when you make 1500 videos
eventually people see some of it i guess
why does marquez brownlee review retro
tech i was born in 1993. it's it's sort
of right in this goldilocks zone where
my parents didn't really get us video
game consoles or anything like that a
lot of the retro tech right around when
i was growing up is lost on me like i
never owned a game boy or a sega genesis
or any of these like early things so it
was cool to go back for this youtube
original show that i did called
retrotech
and
learn about that stuff for the first
time so last but not least why is
marquez brownlee at the met gala that's
a great question are people really
googling that that's a pretty hilarious
um i was invited to the met gala in 2022
i actually don't know the answer to that
question
but i was at the met gala i didn't know
what to expect going in like i'd seen
the red carpet and then i know that
everyone got off the red carpet and went
into some place and i was like oh what's
the place but you really you just go
into the metropolitan museum of art it's
a it's an event that raises money for
the for the museum and you get to meet
some cool people eat some good food and
hang out for a little while before you
go home and wonder if any of it was real
all right how marquez brownlee how does
marquez brownlee pick thumbnails ooh
that's a good question because it
changed recently i used to be for the
first 10 or 11 years the person who
poured all the time and effort into the
youtube video and then as it was
uploading i went
i need a thumbnail and a title and i'd
come up with it in the last minute
that's actually flipped in the past year
or two i've realized the only way anyone
ever finds what you made is if you
package it well so
we start videos now with a title and
thumbnail in mind as we go to create
them all right how does marquez brownlee
scale his brand tech is cool i've been
making a lot of videos on a relatively
narrow window of tech being like we've
seen smartphones rise up and now they're
everywhere but i have interests all over
the tech world electric cars headphones
computers tvs so scale of the brand
really just comes with being able to
talk about and speak to more things and
maybe going to the met gala how did
marquez brownlee interview elon musk i
tweeted at him said hey do you want to
jump on an interview and he was like
yeah
it was cool to just see somebody um in
that position actually know the nuts and
bolts of what's going on we did this in
the factory uh he gave me a tour of the
factory afterwards but like he's
pointing at different machines telling
me exactly what they do i'm sure there
are other business leaders who could
walk through factories and tell me what
they do but that part of it was fun even
before we recorded anything he's like
looking at the camera rig we're using
just asking questions about the gimbal
and like so what is this for what does
this do uh so a nerd from the opening
minutes of our conversation how does
marquez brownlee
go viral don't google that google how to
how does anyone go viral that's the
golden the golden question i found that
the videos that i make that go the most
viral
are
actually pretty predictable because
they're about devices that i know people
care about when the new iphone gets
announced by apple and then they bring
us all into that room and they let us
shoot hands-on with it when i upload
that video i know it's going to do
better than this other thing i'm working
on about this obscure drone that
nobody's heard about
all right this one is is marquez
brownlee so is marquez brownlee good at
ultimate frisbee well i play um and i've
been lucky enough to play in the new
york area which has some of the best
teams in the world so the fact that i'm
on the team
you know i feel like that's a pretty
good indicator i'm a decent player i'm
not the best player though that's for
sure ultimate frisbee loki is one of the
most highlight
friendly
sports you will ever see it's a pretty
young sport but literally average
catches in the ultimate world make espn
top 10 when the footage is good enough
so if you ever get to go to an ultimate
game you'll see it's amazing but
you know the disc flies you've seen
people throw a disc before but it floats
just a little bit and some of those
improbable catches are kind of routine
for the best players in the world so
just go watch some all right is marquez
brownlee okay
there's no more is he okay
i think so what do they know that i
don't know
are marquez brownlee's videos getting
longer
actually yeah that's a really
interesting observation a long video for
me used to be six seven minutes
now
uh i just made a video that was about
eight minutes long and we were all like
that was a really short video could have
been 18 20 minutes long uh is marquez
brownlee
going to space no i don't think so i
mean i would like to that's one of those
like bucket list things i have a bunch
of weird bucket list things i want to do
i want to see a bunch of natural
phenomena i've never seen a tornado but
i also want to go to space that'd be
cool
what marquez brownlee so what phone does
marquez brownlee use so it's going to be
different when i'm testing a different
phone at the moment it's a galaxy s21
ultra and an iphone 13 pro and i do have
personal preferences so when i'm done
testing a phone i'll go back to a phone
that i liked more so in between phones
i'm using the s21 ultra more
but i'm testing another phone next week
and then whatever phone comes out after
that so this is a different answer every
time what
new tech marquez brownlee is excited
about i feel like the obvious future
answer is ar vr but also electric cars
for me i'm really excited about them and
interested in them we've had some ar vr
stuff that's like trickled a little bit
in the past couple years but whenever
you get a new device
and a new piece of hardware to look at
that's when it gets interesting and i
think we're about to start seeing some
more of that what is marquez brownlee's
least favorite tech it's funny i'm a pr
i'm
i'm an optimist about a lot of this
stuff so i don't know if i have a
least favorite you know what's funny
about bad tech sometimes tech is just
ahead of its time like there's the
google glasses of the world where like
10 years ago a camera on your face was a
terrible idea and everybody ended up
hating it but now we're around the
corner from aren't there snapchat
glasses and like ray-bans with cameras
on them like we're all totally okay with
that suddenly so
you know just ahead of his time
all right what does marquez brownlee get
wrong nothing
except for the one time i thought had
three gigs of ram instead of eight or
something probably
what is marquez brownlee's plan well
i've sort of said it before but uh i
make tech videos so my plan is to keep
making them and hopefully make more and
better
all right
who is marquez brownlee's rival
that would be linus sebastian
no where i you know lots of people make
tech videos uh lots of fellow tech
youtubers that were actually all
pretty good friends but for the sake of
the memes let's just say linus who was
marquez brownlee's first subscriber i
feel like i would have to google that to
find out i might be able to find out you
know what's funny i used to have email
notifications on for every activity on
my channel including every new
subscriber i turn those off after i
start getting crazy but i actually i
don't know
ludi marquez brownlee first interview
technically my first ever interview was
with
dennis woodside when he was the ceo of
motorola but my first ever in-person
interview as a basically a child was
kobe bryant
so that was a welcome to the welcome to
the big leagues moment for me which was
uh i'm not a good interviewer clearly
but that was a great way of getting me
used to the idea he's really good at
getting interviewed
who are marquez brownlee's favorite
youtubers i watch a good variety of
youtube a lot of educational channels
the cgp greys of the world a lot of
entertainment channels the mr beasts of
the world a lot of tech channels
like linus so yeah there's a
healthy variety
all right does marquez brownlee does
marquez brownlee
like android or ios
better personally
i have two phones right i carry this
android phone in my right pocket and i
carry the iphone in my left pocket and
my main sim card with the phone number
that i use the most
is in the android phone but i have the
iphone because there's so many things i
have to be familiar with both worlds but
there's so many things that are just a
little bit better on the iphone i have
family group chats and facetimes and all
that but there's also camera stuff
there's some apps that are iphone only
my phone key is on my iphone so it's i'm
i split my time like for real but
i i do prefer
if i could only use one
i would just have the android phone does
marquez brownlee
review ai ah yeah actually i i did
recently you might have heard about
dolly dolly is a ai art generator that
can take any text input that you give it
you just say giraffe writing a
skateboard and we'll take that and turn
it into
photo realistic
high resolution imagery and whatever
style you want and it looks real
it's kind of
incredible i am both optimistic and
fearful of what ai is capable of
you know now
i i can compare the art that the ai
makes to the art that our graphic
designer in the studio makes and the
graphic designer in the studio is better
but we literally did a video comparing
them and he would he would take you know
six hours to make an image and dolly
would take 10 seconds to make an almost
as good image and that is both amazing
and horrifying so he might be fired
i don't think he's fired at any point
but there is something to uh
this ai
quick generation thing does marquez
brownlee what do i do use a red camera
pretty often yes so they make some
incredible cameras i started using them
actually a really long time ago when i
was in college i was
super locked in on canon c100 1080p all
day loved that thing and then i was like
you know what i should try 4k and i
rented a red
scarlet w and
never looked back
i feel like the production value has
actually been growing constantly since
the beginning even though we've used red
cameras for years we do new camera moves
we shoot in new places we have a robot
now if you've ever seen one of those
robot arms that like puts the door on
the side of the car imagine that
but with the camera attached to the side
of it and then a ps5 controller and then
software to keyframe and just move the
camera around it's crazy so we we have
some fun with the camera stuff now does
marquez brownlee have a master class i
actually do yes
i did a master class on
making videos for the internet you can
take a camera and a tripod and a light
and make something amazing and put it on
the internet and accomplish your goals
maybe you want to share something does
marquez brownlee
go clubbing uh
no
no not really i found it kind of a waste
of time i think outside of uh the normal
android ios ai red cameras stuff i i
play golf and uh i play i play video
games that's that's maybe my biggest
time waster at this point
those are some good questions some of
them were a little bit out of left field
but i like that i feel like
just keep mixing up what you guys google
because maybe i come back and there's
some crazy other questions that i get to
answer but until then i'm okay if you're
wondering i'm okay